Hola Muy Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
France 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña y doña Villanueva Ruiz ella
es eurodiputada por el partido español
podemos del cual es además Su secretaria
internacional y doy a Villanueva
Muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
transmity 4
Muchísimas gracias a vosotros por la
invitación encantada de estar aquí no
por favor Gracias a usted de una vez más
bueno recientemente estuvo viajando por
América Latina verdad pasó por Colombia
también por chile y estamos hablando de
dos países que precisamente atraviesan
cambios muy importantes no los países
tras toda una historia de gobierno
conservadores y de derechas finalmente
por primera vez eligieron gobiernos
progresistas verdad como
europarlamentaria de podemos y en
particular como secretaria Internacional
del partido Cómo ve usted de estos
cambios es que imagen se llevó de este
recorrido que hizo por la región de
América Latina
Bueno desde luego en podemos siempre
hemos tenido una visión muy clara
internacionalista no Nosotros llegamos
para ganar derechos en nuestro país pero
también para intentar hacer avanzar a
los pueblos de todo el mundo y en ese
sentido para nosotras América Latina
siempre ha sido un gran referente no y
por lo tanto yo viajo mucho América
Latina y solemos trabajar muy de la mano
con los distintos países
como bien decías hay un cambio no ahora
en Colombia en Chile pero también en la
región con nuevos gobiernos que se
enfrentan a retos múltiples a nivel
internacional pero también Creo que es
una oportunidad ahora mismo para América
Latina para regirse para poder
organizarse en esa integración
territorial y poder pues negociar
también de otra manera a nivel
internacional con Europa con Estados
Unidos con otras potencias que ahora
mismo también atraviesan múltiples
crisis y que con estos cambios de
gobierno también se abre una oportunidad
no como decía para desarrollar esas
relaciones internacionales de una manera
más justa con garantías y con derechos
para los pueblos de América Latina bueno
poco recién adelantaba Y todavía pero se
lo quiero preguntar de manera particular
no como caracterizaría los vínculos
entre América Latina y Europa De dónde
vienen y hacia dónde van
Bueno yo creo que las múltiples crisis
que atraviesan ahora mismo Europa abren
una agenda no hace poco escuchábamos a
la comisión europea diciendo que era
importante relanzar la agenda con
América Latina esto en términos europeos
siempre suele decir profundizar en esa
agenda de acuerdos económicos no
Entonces al mismo tiempo como decía
pienso que es una oportunidad ahora para
la región no poder trabajar en esa
integración territorial y
negociar pues unas nuevas relaciones
internacionales que no sean puramente
comerciales que no sean puramente
extractivistas como han sido hasta ahora
muchas de ellas sino que de alguna
manera permitan desarrollarse de una
manera justa permita garantizar tener de
alguna manera control sobre los propios
recursos de América Latina garantizar
que en esos acuerdos comerciales hay
cláusulas de derechos humanos de
derechos medioambi animales garantizar
pues como decía que de alguna manera
esas relaciones sean con mirada larga y
no puramente económicas en corto plazo
No claro no y unas relaciones más Quizás
entre padres verdad hablabas recién de
las crisis que atraviesan en Europa y me
gustaría hablar de la crisis migratoria
no las imágenes de miles de personas
atravesando la fronteras de Europa o
cruzando el Mediterráneo no muchos
muriendo en el intento Incluso recorren
el mundo desde hace varios años
especialmente de 2016 no con aquel Éxodo
sirio no que afectó tanto a Europa Pero
además de esos peligros enfrentan por
ejemplo cierres de puertos en Europa
políticas migratorias cada vez más duras
países que no recogen embarcaciones con
migrantes políticas de devolución no a
países como por ejemplo Libia que es
bastante hostil para nada seguro para
muchísimas de estas personas recordemos
Perdón me estoy extendiendo un poco pero
recordemos el episodio de melilla no con
más 20 migrantes que intentaron cruzar
no la vaya desde Marruecos a España
murieron aplastados Hacia dónde debería
apuntar la política migratoria de la
Unión Europea es posible que los 27
países adopten un criterio común
No creo que no hay otra otro camino
posible no yo creo que la Unión Europea
ha crecido muy rápidamente de acuerdo
eso a criterios económicos a
sostenibilidad del mercado interior y ha
abandonado todo aquello que hacía
referencia a un proyecto pues social a
un proyecto de derechos y lo que ha
tratado es de construir esa Europa
fortaleza llena de fronteras que están
de alguna manera convirtiendo como bien
indicadas nuestro mediterráneo en una
gran fosa común creo que no hay vallas
ni ni paredes ni fronteras que vayan a
poder parar unas políticas
internacionales injustas y que están
expoliando a los pueblos por tanto creo
que es importante bueno por un lado
y tomar el ejemplo no que ahora con la
Guerra de Ucrania se ha puesto en activo
la directiva de acogida temporal algo
que durante mucho tiempo hemos estado
pidiendo desde podemos para muchos
conflictos
yugoslavia de yemen y que Europa decía
que era imposible acoger ahora
inmediatamente se ha puesto Esa esa
directiva en marcha queremos que tiene
que ser la Norma que rija en todos los
conflictos y que no dependan del color
de la piel la en Europa Pero
además es muy importante trabajar sobre
las causas de la migración de Por qué
las personas se ven obligadas a migrar
migrar tiene que seguir siendo un
derecho no una obligación para poder
salvar la vida y por tanto es
importantísimo cambiar la política
internacional de raíz no como
comentábamos antes en muchos de los
acuerdos comerciales que Hasta ahora ha
hecho la Unión Europea y trabajar en
asada mucho más amplia global no a la
semana pasada se aprobaba en Europa
la nueva política de vecindad Sur no y
en esa mirada seguía siendo una mirada
totalmente economicista y nosotras
reclamábamos y hemos conseguido meter en
ese informe la necesidad de que haya
unas políticas con derechos basadas en
los Derechos Humanos pero que también
dejen de ignorar cuando se viola el
derecho internacional como lo vemos a
diario en en los países del sur no
soportando a gobiernos autoritarios en
vez de los movimientos democráticos de
las personas o ignorando cuando Israel
tiene sistemáticamente una pared contra
Palestina o cuando Marruecos ignora las
necesidades de autodeterminación del
pueblo saharaui o cuando erdogan con
Turquía acosa al pueblo kurdo no Europa
no puede estar de espaldas a las
violaciones de derecho internacional y
debe ir a las causas de Por qué hay
tanta gente dejándose la vida intentando
Buscar un futuro no es muy importante
por un lado como parecía que esa Europa
acoja que esa directiva de acogida esté
en todos los conflictos y allá donde las
personas Bueno pues están vulnerables y
ponen en riesgo su vida Pero además ir a
las causas de esa migración forzosa en
las que muchas personas pues se ven
obligadas para salvar la vida
mencionaba recién la guerra en Ucrania
por supuesto No porque estábamos
hablando de la crisis migratoria
muchísimos refugiados llegan a Europa se
viene el invierno europeo y asistimos
bueno una crisis energética producto
como decimos del conflicto bélico y el
tema de las energías ha estado presente
en la agenda de podemos incluso desde
antes no de la guerra pero este
conflicto armado deja al descubierto no
que este tema es absolutamente clave
Europa propone grabar los beneficios
extraordinarios de las compañías
energéticas también limitar el precio
del gas Cómo creen que debe abordarse
este escenario
Bueno yo creo que hay que atajar ahora
mismo las medidas urgentes a lo tácticos
sin dejar de hacer una reflexión más
amplia de cómo Hemos llegado hasta aquí
que hay que cambiar en una mirada medio
plazo no esta guerra Nos está dejando
miles de Muertos millones de desplazados
y el alza de precios de energía de los
alimentos en todo el mundo y aquí
queremos dejar lo primero que me
gustaría es dejar muy claro que la mejor
medida ante crisis es conseguir la paz
no Y desde luego una crítica muy directa
no al papel de la Unión Europea en este
sentido porque creemos que no se están
haciendo todos los esfuerzos que se
podrían hacer diplomáticos Y de
construcción de paz y que el jefe de la
diplomacia europea le hemos escuchado
decir esta guerra se ganará en el campo
de batalla de momento quien está ganando
en esta guerra son las grandes
energéticas las empresas armamentísticas
el dólar frente al Euro Europa ha pasado
depender del gas de Rusia a depender del
los Estados Unidos con técnicas de
fracking que van en contra de nuestros
propios acuerdos contra el cambio
climático y por tanto vuelvo a repetir
la mejor medida hoy es sería la
construcción de la Paz El Alto el fuego
y la construcción de una paz ahora bien
han puesto el espejo como bien decías
sobre esa transición energética que no
se ha llevado a cabo en la que vamos
tarde y sobre todo no llevamos años
desde podemos diciendo esa necesidad de
topar los precios en las energéticas es
un escándalo Y es vergonzoso que estén
hoy beneficiándose el gran oligopolio
energético con situaciones como la
guerra mientras vamos a tener millones
de familias que no son capaces de pagar
las facturas llevamos años diciendo esa
necesidad de topar los precios de poner
impuestos a la banca Y en este caso a
las energéticas también y bueno hemos
oído a lo largo de estos años acusarnos
de todo no y hoy vemos como la comisión
europea precisamente señala a todos los
países europeos sobre la necesidad de de
topar esos precios de poner estos
impuestos para poder afrontar el
invierno nosotros pensamos que llegamos
que llegamos tarde también nos ha
costado mucho convencer al socio de
gobierno en España al partido socialista
de ello de algo que es hoy un consenso
no pensamos que llegamos tarde que es
bueno que exista ese consenso pero que
desde luego
frente a las medidas improvisar
improvisadas ahora mismo de la Unión
Europea es necesario tener una agenda
con estrategia que nos permita ahondar
en esa transición energética con
energías renovables y poder trabajar en
esa autonomía pegada a los territorios
No yo me gustaría abordar con ustedes
ahora un tema que está muy debate en
estos días porque la reciente muerte no
en Reino Unido de la fallecida Reina
Isabel segunda puso un relieve una vez
más No el rol de las monarquías sus
funciones Y por supuesto también las
críticas hacia este sistema
postura y la de podemos respecto de
seguir teniendo una monarquía aspiran a
que España sea una República
Bueno podemos vino a ganar derechos para
nuestros pueblos en nuestro país pero
también la democratizar las estructuras
de nuestro estado No desde luego Una
institución que se elige por sangre es
de todo menos democrática no En ese
sentido nosotras pensamos que durante
muchos años la esta estructura ha
servido precisamente para guardar la
impunidad no tenemos un rey huido de
nuestro país que antes de enfrentarse a
la justicia ha tenido que huir a otro
país y que hoy está protegido por leyes
de inviolabilidad no nosotros pensamos
que todo el mundo te debe de ser igual
ante la justicia y que en ese sentido
nuestro país está preparado
democráticamente para avanzar a que el
jefe del estado se ha elegido de una
manera democrática y no por vínculos de
sangre no Y doy a Villanueva Ruiz
Muchísimas gracias pasó volando esta
entrevista gracias por haber participado
en Francia 24 un placer os mando un
abrazo muy grande a todos y todas
seguimos el placer ha sido nuestro
Gracias una vez más a nuestra audiencia
como siempre la invitamos a que sigan
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto como
siempre en transmitir 4.com sigan junto
a nosotros
[Música]